the dark continent is one of the most
mysterious and intrigue-filled
destinations in all of media it is an
impossibly large landmass featuring a
planetary size lake and right in the
middle of that lake is the teeny tiny
human realm of the thousands of people
who have been to the dark continent only
a handful have returned and the survival
rate is said to be 0.04 percent the
continent itself is filled with great
potential apocalyptic horrors and a
sheer scale unlike any world we've ever
seen before and we are currently on a
mission to explore it hello and welcome
to the new order of your source for
honestly just hunter hunter my name is
liam and i'm here to tell you everything
you need to know about the dark
continent this is going to be part one
of a recap series designed to give you
all of the information you need to be
ready for the return of hunter hunter
and one of the most basic foundations we
need is why and how we are currently
traveling to the dark continent and
things are going to get very out of hand
very quickly because there is so much
happening from the various global
parties interested in this continent but
the important thing to remember is that
this all started because of one man and
his name is beyond netero none of what
we're seeing right now would be
happening without him because he's
effectively manipulated three global
superpowers into commencing this
expedition beyond is an unparalleled
living genius but what's more terrifying
is that he is the son of one of the most
powerful individuals to have ever
existed he is the spawn of former
chairman isaac netaro and he may very
well have even surpassed his father's
abilities as demonstrated by the very
own the nose name of beyond netter
takashi is uh he's not particularly
subtle with names in hunter hunter but
by far the most terrifying thing is that
we do not know what beyond's exact
motivations are what we do know is that
his father was very wary of him and has
even charged the hunter association with
thwarting his various plans meaning that
beyond is being set up to become the
primary antagonist of this arc and in
order for him to reach the dark
continent he needs four things
permission qualifications the means and
a contract beyond on his own does
possess one of these which is
qualifications as he has actually been
on a previous expedition so he does have
the experience needed to act as a guide
more on that later though because the
other three things are like very
important in terms of means beyond has
convinced kygnosabee of the kakin empire
to fund the trip kakin being this
absolutely massive isolated empire in
the world and was not part of the
current v5 ruling body which i guess is
kind of like our equivalent of the
united nations just
much more effective but king nasabi
wants a lot more than to simply explore
the continent his plan is to actually
move the empire and settle on the dark
continent ideally taking something of a
monopoly on its resources and turning
the kakin empire into the undisputed
world power however king nasty does have
a further twist in mind nasubi has
decided to use the voyage to host a
kakin ritual known as the succession war
which is essentially a death game
between the princes of the empire with
the sole survivor inheriting the title
of king but that that is a whole
different pandora's box that we will
need to open at a later date the second
faction beyond succeeded in manipulating
where the aforementioned v5 this is a
group of five nations who have each had
unsuccessful voyages to the dark
continent in the past and others now
acting as something of a global blockade
to dark continent travel what beyond
needed from the v5 was permission and he
obtained it like shockingly easily i
might add because as soon as the khakian
empire declared their intentions to
explore the dark continent the v5 were
left with three choices one go to war
with the kakin empire in order to stop
them from doing the thing two let them
go and do the thing and potentially
bring back a humanity-destroying
calamity with them or three join forces
with the empire and explore the
continent together and the v5 went with
option three transforming their
organization into the v6 in terms of
important characters we should flag
steiner he is a high ranking official
from a rather boringly named
organization called the international
permit agency but as such steiner is the
official head of this expedition
although he himself is incredibly aware
of the endeavour as everything he has
read about the dark continent shook him
to his core steiner himself believes
that the dark continent is not a place
humanity should return to under any
circumstances and yet here he is doing
the thing it is that he didn't want to
do but now that we have qualifications
permission and means what we need is a
contract something that binds everyone
together nice and tightly and that is
where the hunter association comes in
new chairman shiro yorkshire and the
remaining zodiacs were provided with a
video will from isaac natara imploring
them to explore the dark continent and
find some benefit for humanity but most
importantly to do so before his son
beyond and so the association agreed to
provide security on the voyage which i
think is important to point out the
association is not in charge of this
journey they are mere players like
everyone else also following the
resignation of both jing and paristan
the zodiacs had two free slots to film
one of which was taken by leorio mostly
due to his name recognition as now
accidentally one of the most famous
living hunters as a result of the
chairman election but he's basically
there for moral support people like
leorio and they believe in leorio and
therefore having him lead the charge on
this impossible voyage is well it's
comforting i guess more tangibly useful
though is the second zodiac slot which
was filled by karapika who has inherited
the mantle of series protagonist
assisting the zodiacs in organizing the
trip and even managing to discover a
sneaky spy in their ranks which is siu
sayo is actually working for beyond
netro and the zodiacs know that but
saiyu doesn't know that they know so
there's all sorts of like crazy
intriguing play it's also important to
flag that karapika is on his own mission
because he has some personal business
with one of the kakin princes who
possesses the remaining scarlet eyes of
his clan so karapika isn't acting
strictly professionally here there's a
lot of strong emotion and narrative
drama threatening to get in the way also
of note is that the hunter association
currently has beyond netero in custody
because he turned himself over to them
for reasons that are currently kind of
unclear but apparently we're all
according to plan as he and the three
factions he manipulated have now boarded
a gigantic ship that looks like a fun
cartoon whale and are now on route to
the dark continent is it on route or on
route i never remember but i don't care
because now that we know how we got here
a big question that needs answering is
why the crap we are going to the most
dangerous place on the planet and the
simple answer to that would be resources
the dark continent is packed full of
items and materials that would
revolutionize humanity as we know it the
most commonly excited example of this is
nitro rice said to hold the ultimate
secret of longevity and it's also
thought that nitra rice is behind the
superhuman old ages of characters like
isaac natural and mahazalde because they
could be quite literally centuries old
there's also an item designated the name
unknown herb said to be capable of
curing all disease like the goal of them
as well as an object called unmanned
rock a single bead of which can
allegedly generate up to 20 kilowatts of
power a day when placed underwater and i
guess to put that into perspective
according to google the average
australian household uses up to 18
kilowatts of power per day so i suppose
if we all had to have tiny rocks instead
of whatever we have now then we could
revolutionize power and stuff as we know
it not gonna lie not entirely over how
power works
can you tell other dark continent
substances are mentioned but their
effects are very vaguely defined what is
clear is that even the smallest
discovery on this landmass could lead to
the greatest spurt of evolution that
humanity has ever experienced so there's
a high reward but there is also an
equally as high in fact much higher risk
because just as anything found on this
land could enhance existence an
overwhelming amount of things are also
capable of ending that existence in
particular there are a group of
calamities known as the five threats
which were curses placed on humanity
after the unsuccessful v5 voyages these
consist of i a gaseous creature dubbed
as the co-dependence of desire and to
give you a bit of an idea of what an eye
is capable of while nanika is actually
an eye and with but a simple wish nanika
could destroy the entire human race to
be fair that's going to be a bit of a
common theme though because any of these
things could wipe out humanity like that
that was a that was a weak click i'm
right-handed but like my right hand goes
off screens sorry so i had to go with
left the next threat is brionne a
botanical weapon that is said to protect
a series of ancient ruins on the
continent which i find very interesting
because it does imply that life once
existed there in some sort of organized
fashion then there is the utterly
terrifying pap a group of unseen
entities that suck the life out of
humans and not only that but they make
them enjoy the experience having been
defined as the trade-off between life
and pleasure and also they have the
tendency to keep humans as teeny tiny
pets which is not appealing then there's
zobai also known as the immortality
disease said to be endless despair
disguised as hope those infected are
doomed to live forever in a constant
state of pain and suffering i actually
think that's the worst one so far
meanwhile our fifth calamity is hellbell
a twin-tailed snake said to infect its
prey with raw homicidal desire and now
in case that sounds underwhelming
according to the official hunter
statistics hellbell is considered a more
dangerous threat than even the chimera
ants in fact all of these threats are
considered more dangerous than the ants
so remember king merowem who was
effectively a god who almost took over
the world and wiped us all out well all
of these things are considered an even
bigger threat than him but also fun fact
the chimera ants do originate from the
dark continent as well as every magical
beast in the hunter hunter world so it's
safe to say that humanity has made a lot
of trips 149 trips to be precise and
those are just the official ones and as
a result humanity has come back with a
lot of curses and speaking of 149 that's
a lot of trips and aside from the failed
v5 expeditions we do know of several
others two voyages of which were
allegedly conducted by isaac netaro
himself and in fact most of what we've
seen from the dark continent comes
directly from his flashback a young
netro traveled to the dark continent
along with his friends linnea auderve
and zigzaldik who may or may not also be
mahazarik like everything in hunter
hunter is complicated and i do have a
whole video about it sooner you can go
watch that if you're interested if not
stay here but nataro initially visited
the continent in order to seek out a
strong opponent however when he arrived
he found that the only victory to be had
was survival which isn't great because
he had that before and as for his second
trip we don't even have a single shred
of information about it what we do know
is that after successfully returning
twice netro lobbied the v5 to ban travel
to the dark continent deeming it simply
too dangerous to even entertain as a
possibility we do know of at least one
other successful expedition though
although it was a one-way trip curiously
enough the vast majority of what
humanity knows about the dark continent
comes from a very old book called
journey to the new world east edition
penned by a man named don freaks who was
said to have traveled to the dark
continent a mind bending 300 years ago
don freaks is also highly likely to be
related to jing and gone freaks because
well because that's how storytelling
works but don's mission was to travel
around the vast shoreline of lake mobius
and log his experiences so yes don's
mission was to more or less rim the dark
continent even more curious though is
that the companion book journey to the
new world west edition was never found
leaving jing to speculate that don had
not yet finished writing it which i
think more so than anything gives you a
really solid scale for just how big this
place is it's taken 300 years and don
hasn't even completed a full trip around
the shoreline and we haven't even begun
to step inland yet although technically
as far as the series goes we haven't
even stepped onto the shore because
getting to the dark continent is well
it's not as simple as hopping on your
sailboat and doing a bit of a well a bit
of a sail because it's actually said to
be physically impossible for humans to
cross the ocean boundaries leading to
the continent we're not entirely sure
why that is but it could be because the
environment and the weather is just far
too apocalyptic for anyone or anything
to survive so that leaves us with one
option at an as of yet unknown location
there exists a race of magical beasts
known as the gatekeepers now in a manner
that i'm going to describe as somehow
these gatekeepers are able to provide
safe passage to the dark continent by
summoning a being known as the guide the
guide is highly likely to be a nen beast
crafted by the aura of the gatekeepers
and despite its name the guide is
actually well it's quite a sinister
presence because sure it'll take people
to the dark continent as per its job
description but the guide is also
responsible for cursing humanity with a
threat after a failed voyage sort of
like a punishment for the hubris as well
as a warning of like hey maybe don't do
this again having said that there may
potentially be a way to get to the
continent without going through the
gatekeepers because steiner has implied
that an unofficial voyage did succeed in
making a round trip all by themselves so
just as with everything in this series
it's not quite as black and white as it
seems however it may or may not matter
because to be perfectly honest there is
every chance that we are not even going
to be able to get there because right
now everyone aboard the blackwell one
seems to be doing their absolute best to
ensure that that ship sinks the mafia
families are causing chaos the phantom
trooper out in full force hisoka is
prancing around like a sneaky magician
each prince of the kakin empire is
actively trying to kill one another and
meanwhile the hunter association is
struggling against all odds simply to
hold things together all of which is
going to be covered in part two the
succession war